ils y étaient à San
Francisco toute la ville
brûlait et ces mecs là il prenaient des
photos on aurait dit qu'il s'attendait
que
ça tu crois que votre père travailla
avec ses hommes on a trouvé ça dans son
coffre qui êtes-vous c'est quoi
monarque
c'est le monde dans lequel nous vivons
les monstres sont une réalité à laquelle
on peut
échapper ces fichiers nous appartiennent
ils sont bien plus importants que ce que
vous pourriez
imaginer cette vision va me donner des
cauchemars alors soit vous croyez les
mensonges de
monar sur la disparition de votre
père soit on essaie de découvrir ce qui
lui est vraiment
arrivé avant qu'il soit trop
[Musique]
tard c'est pas vrai cours cours cours ce
monde ne nous appartient pas vous pouvez
me
croire il est nettement plus vaste que
ce qu'on imagine même dans nos rêves les
plus forts
[Musique]
c'est monstr et
monar il m vol tout ce que
j'avais c'est
termin le monde est en train de brûler
si vous voulez sauver des millions de
vies on a besoin de toute l'a poss
possible
r
C